hi uh carrying on from the
the last film i made
does your aikido work
so mr faye my tai chi master
how do you make mass power
how can you throw somebody as if they're
like a piece of paper
to you they weigh nothing you just
call forth all your relaxation
that you can have in your body at the
same time
you call everything forward and you
you do a throw you do a technique
if you've done a nickel or a senko or
any immobilization with this type of
power
sadly it snaps their
elbow their arm their wrist
it's not a good sound when i was
a very low grade i'd i was training the
karate person
and he resisted and i didn't know any
better
and i looked at the technique that i was
shown and i'd done it
and his wrist snapped and it sounded
like a very large
carrot being nice crispy raw carrot
being snapped
straight away i apologize didn't realize
what i'd done
he said he looked at me and said oh
don't worry i've had it broken before
i mean what an idiotic thing to say
i was devastated because i never really
wanted to hurt anybody
but he resisted when we were halfway
through the technique
and because the technique was strong
perhaps i was strong as well but because
the technique was strong
to try and stop a technique that's got
that's working
and truly working you're mad to try and
stop it
psychosensia always said you must not
resist or
fight this is not
what's asked of in this dojo in the
iwama dojo there was a sign
and it said you would be asked to leave
the dojo if you're found
fighting i'd like to show you this book
again from my tai chi master
again you can see him in the air
and there's some more pictures here
of him with the spear
now the reason i'm showing you them is
if you get the technique correct
and focus your mind concentration
with a flexible body all on the one
thing that you're trying to do you can
create
mass power but you do need the technique
to be right
so technique to me is everything
so he gave me this spear
and asked me for a screwdriver we
unscrewed
the metal spear from the bamboo pole
he asked me for a small wet bearing
so my father used to repair
bicycles so i went to the drawer
got a small bearing he placed it in
there
and he was teaching me how he was taught
and when you're a child
the grandfather teaches you
so in his early childhood
his grandfather would teach him and
develop him
and show him his tai chi
wu shu will say would you the western
wild noses are
cool for her so i'll say
worship when you become
what they consider a mature person
your own father starts to teach you
when you've grown up if your
grandfather's still around
you perhaps got a family of your own
you've matured
your grandfather comes back to teach you
again
so there's a whole process now
the person that said michael who works
for me
i've been on seminars
in my younger days and mike you know
didn't work for me
because what i'd done was every month i
would try to find a seminar somewhere
and i would go to in the uk and with all
the different styles sometimes i was
fine
my techniques worked and other times it
just didn't
in this uh covey period we've had a lot
of time
to study
well i have any study youtube
and a lot of what i see this is being
very judgmentally
is awful it's really terrible
like i sometimes wonder how they can
call it aikido
and yeah the first one i'd like to talk
about in one
is it's in my book but you don't
need to buy my book to do it doesn't
matter whether it's a
sankhya pen but
you get to to this position
okay and you can see
even the top masters sankyo nikki
ho they get the person down they're in
swadiwoza
look at the youtube prove me wrong
even the very very top japanese masters
you'll see them doing this
they do the pin on the straight arm
being locked
against the chest and then they go
and they fold it they go and fold the
arm
after they've done the technique
where you'll see this cross
like that now
if you want to be a martial artist
and like mr faye he put the ball baron
in the spearhead
and he made me day after day
thrust with that spear
and he said when he first showed me
when it sounds like this you have it
correct
he thrust and you heard the ball bearing
bang as if it was like a the bang
of a child's cat gun you know it was
the crack was so loud and precise
that you could tell not just technique
but the power he sent down that bamboo
pole
so to me training to be a
martial artist needs you to be precise
and work hard towards it
you've just taken somebody because you
to me you should think marshall all the
time you've just taken somebody
they've gone to attack you whether it be
on the map or in the street
you shouldn't distinguish you should try
and do the best technique you can
all the time a constant
this word zanchin it means awareness so
you don't have to be
like looking everywhere scared up down
saying you're going to attack me in the
end you relax the eyes and you see
you know up down
side to side you relax by relaxed eyes
even though i'm looking at the camera
i'm seeing everything
in my proliferation to the sides
now i've just got this guy i've pinned
him down
look at the demonstrations on youtube
like i say
you've pinned him down you've made him
tap and then you go and fired his arm
politely put it on his back that's not
marshall
that is where i get really frustrated
that it's done there's a
there's another one that i'd like to
just show you i'm not going to go into
great detail
but the next one is a kodakage everybody
loves coated ice around the world
kind of gosh as we know it is a small
wrist twist
a small wrist twist okay
if you look at the picture here it shows
the elbow bent
if the elbow is bent it's not a smallest
twist anymore
and it means that you've helped okay to
be able to
pull in his arm so you can pull it back
in
and you won't get a coat of ice because
he'll be more powerful
than you coped guys is a small wrist
twist
so you eject the person to right angles
and yet look at the videos
the next thing i'd like to show you is
why go back to back on a coat of ice the
person comes to grab
show nucci or the attack various attacks
i believe that when we feel first
started
most of us panicked because we're just
beginners you know we panicked and if
somebody comes to
strike you then you'll panic
and sense he said aikido is redirecting
someone's power
you can't redirect it if you only grasp
their
hand or wrist at the bottom of their
strike
you have to blend with it as it comes
down
shadowing them and you then redirect it
so this means you control
to where it goes
this picture here you'll see
i have it where my navel is it's about
where your
belt knot would be
please take
a pay attention to this because most
people would have it much
further down between their legs even the
obama people
they will there's a close-up
okay of how you hold it
but i've blended down to that point
if we go back to when we panicked
and we just follow it down
even top iwama teachers i see them
taking it down below that point look at
cytosense's videos look at his books and
you'll notice it's where
mine is i'm not saying i'm the greatest
aikidoka because i'm not
i'm just saying that perhaps i see
things
differently to how others said
if you take that down
in between your legs you have to bring
it back
up to throw so
those 30 centimeters
further that you've allowed that arm to
go
because you have to bring it back up it
comes up in a circle
it can't be ejected at a right angle
from the center point near your belt it
can be ejected from that point
with a very short left hardly anything
take it between the legs and you have to
lift it
that makes it circular and by making it
circular
that is why that arm was bending on the
other picture
so we are causing our own problems
our own weaknesses
the last one i'd like to show you now
is kaitenaggi i see
in kaitenagi again top japanese
westerners everybody they
they put the hand this picture here
they put the hand there on the head
some even put it deeper right under the
neck
this is incorrect this takes strength
if we look at this picture
you'll notice that i'm on the crown of
the head
and his arm is upright
so these are just snapshots of what i'm
showing you
but you should be able to hold the arm
two fingers or one finger on the crown
of the head
and that it's a forward motion
slightly down and in towards their body
if you can't do it with one finger
and control your partner
then you're not doing aikido
because a small person and a live person
should be able to do those senses i
could have
we but we've all believed this but a
small person can't
do hand on the back of the neck here
or or anywhere on the head because a
strong person
can stand up or press against it
when you get chance to try it try it but
please look at
you know spend your time looking on
youtube they do it
they hold the back of the neck they turn
the partner and throw them
this is when uk is happy to
just take the ukemi i'm not
i have to have the technique done on me
and it must work i won't resist it
but it must work
if you do what i tell you if you the
crown of the head
slightly forward in the correct
direction
a child could i've shown this on even
video somewhere where a child is
controlling a large adult
because the angles are correct
since he said the technique is strong
tony you don't have to be
okay so i hope you've enjoyed those
small pieces i hope to talk a lot more
about technical in the future
and thank you for your time please
subscribe to my channel if you're
keen and i hope in the future
to give more thank you
if you do wish to buy my books you can
find them on amazon